after a nearly nine-month absence Breeze
is finally back in the valorant
competitive map pool but now that we've
all had a few weeks to try it out I'm
now asking myself
did Riot somehow make it worse
[Music]
before we get into the breeze changes
I'd like to thank our friends over at
Shopify for sponsoring today's video you
all know about Shopify Rebellion they're
committed to Esports across all
different titles whether that be
valorant League of Legends DOTA rocket
league and more and with their
state-of-the-art facilities they truly
arm the rebels and just as Shopify
Powers the Rebellion Shopify Powers
businesses too if you're an online
business then Shopify is the easiest way
to sell your products in fact it's
actually how we sell our merch here at
the score Esports including the cult
favorite touchgrass hoodie Shopify is an
all-in-one Commerce platform that
simplifies everything you need in order
to start grow and manage your dream
business and that's why millions of
entrepreneurs across 175 countries rely
on it every day use their starter plan
to set up a Shopify business in minutes
and share your amazing products on
social media if you're a business owner
looking to level up your game then get a
free Shopify trial at shopify.com the
score Esports using the link below now
back to the video all right so a few
weeks back valent removed fracture and
Pearl and replaced them with Sunset and
Breeze Sunset is The Game's newest map
and so far it feels pretty good to me
but we'll just have to wait and see how
the meta develops there but with Breeze
Riot did make some changes to the map
just as we all expected they closed off
one side of mid and added jump up boxes
extended the walls on the perimeter of
b-site and added more jump up boxes then
they blocked off Halls so you can't walk
through it but can still see past
similar to that spot near B-side on
icebox in the last big change Riot made
was closing off Cave to help Defenders
retake a site a bit easier they said
that the goal of these changes aims to
add more trade-offs to A and B site
slams that utilize post-plant utility to
secure the round while adding more
incentive for attackers to control mid
to exert pressure throughout the map but
when players saw the new Breeze there
were definitely mixed reactions
your stay in Paradise has been upgraded
at the start of episode 7 Act 2 Breeze
will return to the map rotation with a
few changes fracture and pearl will
rotate Out preview the changes below
oh wait what the is this
so
what it used to look like and this is
what it looks like now whoa this is so
much better
I like this
wow
this is good I like this but now that
I've had some time with the map and we
all played it last week for Premiere I'm
really not a fan of a lot of the changes
players used to call Breeze an a map for
its long sight lines and I feel like
it's kind of lost that identity not
having to worry about Halls is nice on
defense and retaking a does feel better
now that your opponents can't just hide
at the back of cave and run the clock
down but Paul's does feel kind of
pointless now like a like a very
essential
like part of Breeze and like the breeze
feeling and like game plan was halls and
they just like Halls is useless
like nobody even uses it nobody goes
there nobody Peaks it it's like why do
you even
why did they even cover it up like it
was like they put like little holes that
you could peek through too like for what
having no Halls is kind of weird because
before the allowed for a lot of like
strategies so you can do a hall split
you can flank Bridge
um and you can also flank as a Defender
from Halls so it's like there's it costs
so much pressure and now there's just no
halls and I don't even know why it's
still there to be honest the Halls
change is definitely a weird one but I
don't think it's nearly as bad as some
of the other parts of the map Riot said
that they wanted to incentivize
attackers to take good control but I
feel extremely vulnerable when I jump up
on those boxes even when I use flashes
or other utility before peaking nest and
elbow instead I find myself favoring the
other side of mid which sometimes forces
you into an a split where Defenders now
have that easier retake but in my
opinion worst of all is B sight unless
my opponents decide to over Peak and
throw it around like this retaking
v-site just feels awful now be sight and
Halls yeah like that might be one of the
worst maps uh one of the worst sights
I've ever played in a technical FPS
like it's bad
I don't I don't like it at all again I
just feel like these uses like these
changes are useless and um they kind of
did them to do them and
I know before
I remember correctly like breeze is one
of the few mobs in Pro play that was
like almost 50 50 attack and defense
sided and now I don't even know what
it's gonna but like if something's 50 50
what's the point of changing it but to
be fair although the map may have been
balanced for pro play I do feel like it
was pretty stale before Riot removed it
from the map Pool you'd Viper wall onto
a plant the bomb and then play the post
plant from cave every round and
although these changes help with that
one specific scenario Riot has
unfortunately created other problems and
not to mention that Harbor wasn't even
out last time Breeze was in the pool so
I wouldn't be surprised if this map that
was previously dominated by Viper
utility now just becomes a harbor Viper
wall simulator and I really hope that it
doesn't because that's the reason why a
lot of us hated watching Pearl earlier
this year it sucks they fixed Pearl only
to replace it with another map that
could suffer from the same issue and I
know that it's only been out for a few
weeks so maybe I'm overreacting and
maybe I just need to give it time for
The Meta to just cook a bit more as of
right now I'm really not a fan of this
rework but what do you guys think of the
new Breeze changes
I'm going to Oktoberfest
way to dox me
oh my God check this out did you go out
and buy that or order it oh I've been to
Oktoberfest like many years and I've had
this hat for
probably the past five or six years all
right okay yeah
so you drink beer and eat German food
and uh have a good time